[Music]
wham-o itself being here throughout five
generations is a radical act and the
fact that we're opening our doors to
engage with our community in another way
takes that to the next level to bend the
word threat trying to integrate a social
mission into the work that we do here
for me it's also cultivating my own
relationship with Chinatown as it
changes this great big story is brought
to you by Delta when we venture out into
the world we see all that we share
[Music]
my name is male um I'm the fifth
generation owner of wing on whoa and
also the founder and director of the Wow
project wing on low is the oldest
continually run store in Chinatown it
was started by my great great
grandfather in 1890 today wing on whoa
sells a collection of porcelain wing um
Oh is completely family-run the store
has been throughout the years like our
family living room it's where we meet up
where we hang out there's a kitchen in
the back we're not only selling
porcelain pieces but we're also
supporting the community through the
work that we do with the Wow project and
we're doing that through arts and
activism
at the time when Chinatown was forming
we had no other place to go we were
being pushed out and marginalized so we
had to in order to survive create these
China towns as a safe space there's
still recent immigrants that are coming
to America and meaning a space to land
but Chinatown's around the country are
at a very pivotal moment with their
longevity and reassessing their purpose
in serving these immigrant communities a
[Music]
lot of different Asian Americans who
aren't even Chinese come to Chinatown to
grocery shop to learn about their
culture and their identity
[Music]
for me the story itself has been a
landing and launching pad in my life to
understand my Asian American identity to
understand Chinese culture and history
as well as my sense of self and sense of
grounding in this community after I
graduated college I decided to live and
work abroad
for eight years I came back hoping to
apply to grad school but right before I
hopped on the plane back my dad had
called me and told me we are thinking
about selling the business and the
building I always had relied on having
this space as a constant so when I
realized that this was not going to be
here anymore that's when you start
thinking about how can I continue this
legacy
[Music]
I never ever thought that I would be
taking over the store but I started
learning about gentrification and
displacement not really opened my eyes
to the larger context that my family
situation was existing in I had to make
that decision if I was going to do
something about it
when I took over I had a lot of
interactions with all these people in my
community about what they care about and
I was in a position to do something so
we started a community initiative out of
the storefront called the Wow project we
do host different public programs in the
storefront space like screenings talks
readings it seemed as if there were
serpents in ocean I fought to be with my
son we have a structured residency
program that we offer up to an emerging
Asian American artist we also have a
youth internship program it really runs
the gamut
the largest event that we hold is our
anniversary fundraiser
[Music]
and we've outgrown the store so just to
see how many people came out it was
really incredible Chinatown has been
like such a safe haven for me and I am
happy that I was able to like grow up in
this space because it's grounding me so
for me it's amazing to hear that that's
the same thing for other folks that's
the dream right so much of this year has
been about strengthening our community
so to the well team thank you for your
heart soul creativity and imagination we
want people to be able to cultivate
themselves nurture themselves here and
be able to like do even bigger and
better things beyond us
[Music]